[Music]
consciousness disclosed this antithesis
through action acting in accordance with
the knowledge revealed it finds out that
knowledge is deceptive and being
committed as regards the content of that
knowledge to one of the attributes of
substance it violated the other and so
gave it the right as against itself
in following the god that knows it
really got hold of what was not revealed
and pays the penalty of trusting a
knowledge whose ambiguity for such is
its nature also becomes explicit for
consciousness and a warning to it
the ravings of the priestess the inhuman
shape of the witches the voices of trees
and birds dreams and so forth are not
the ways in which truth manifests itself
they are the warning signs of deception
of an absence of self-possession of the
singularity and contingency of the
knowing or in other words the opposite
power which is violated by consciousness
is present as expressed law and valid
right whether law of the family or of
the state consciousness on the other
hand
followed its own way of knowing and
concealed from itself what was openly
revealed
the truth however from the opposing
powers of the content of the knowledge
and of consciousness is the result that
both are equally right and therefore in
their antithesis
which is brought about by action are
equally wrong
the action in being carried out
demonstrates their unity in the natural
downfall of both powers and both
self-conscious characters the
reconciliation of the opposition with
itself is the lathe a of the underworld
in death or the late they have the upper
world as absolution not from guilt
for consciousness cannot deny its guilt
because it committed the act but from
the crime
both are oblivion the vanishness of the
reality and the action of the powers of
substance other individualities and of
the powers of the abstract thought of
good and evil for none of them by itself
is the essence which rather is the
repose of the whole within itself the
unmoved unity of fate the peaceful
existence and consequent inactivity and
lack of vitality of family and
government and the equal honor and
consequent indifferent unreality of
apollo and the furies and the return of
their spiritual life and activity into
the unitary being of zeus
there is a lot going on in paragraph 740
and what you notice is that hegel
is referencing the
schemas that he's worked out in the last
several paragraphs particularly the
previous paragraph where there were all
of these
associations of three things connected
with each other that we had to plot out
and much of that schema is being
retained
but now
all of the things are being put into
different relations with each other and
in particular
with acting handling consciousness voice
sign
leading ultimately to
talking about zeus and we'll get to that
in a moment when you think zeus in this
case though as where we're headed don't
think about the
the usual depictions of him as the you
know big
white-haired guy in a toga throwing
lightning bolts or any of that sort of
stuff
thank god because that's zaus
part of what it means within a
philosophical context and also within
certain religious contexts it's coming
from the word for god
uh in in greek and that's part of what's
going on here according to hegel in the
transformation that's happening
in greek tragedy as we're going to move
to
comedy so let's let's pick up at the
very start
he says consciousness disclosed
this antithesis
through action antithesis in this case
is gagen zots
and
um as opposed to you know
you know other possibilities so giggins
that's there's an opposition of you
could say
frameworks to each other i think that we
can also
read into this
the gazettes of law
that's going to be talked about quite a
lot a little bit later in this paragraph
so we have laws that are also opposed to
each other or moral norms opposed to
each other so consciousness disclosed
this through
action through
through acting
in a coherent intentional way in a
meaningful way we might say
acting in accordance with the knowledge
revealed right the knowledge that has
been
opened up to it there's a lot of opening
and hiding and and concealing
language going on in this as well
it finds out that the knowledge is
deceptive so what it took originally as
being
certain
if we want to use the you know hegelian
schema
of moving from certainty
to truth right gevis height to var
height and then back again
we're finding that the truth of things
is that they're not as certain as we
thought they were
and he's going to frame this in terms of
the god
who knows the and god here can be
not just you know god is zeus as a
matter of fact we're talking about god
you might save in lowercase
g in this case
he says in following the god that knows
it really got hold
of what was not revealed
and here we're going to see this term
uh open bond right and that is going to
show up in just a few more paragraphs
when we get to the
revealed religion right the religion of
revelation
so we have this dialectic as we've seen
before
in trusting the god who seems to know
we're trusting
something that's not completely clear
here something that
hasn't been revealed that might be the
opposite
of what we think the oracle is a fine
example of this don't trust the words of
the oracle because they usually get you
into some sort of trouble so backing up
a little bit
being committed he says as regards the
content the inhalt of that knowledge
to one of the attributes of substance
namely one of the things that it could
have
understood and mastered
he says it violated the other
and gave it the right as against itself
this is one of those you can't win
sort of situations or as we say
sometimes damned if you do damned if you
don't or you're just screwed right it's
not quite a catch-22 because that has a
complex circular structure in this case
it's rather diffused consciousness
cannot even though it's being earnest
even though it is
acting with good intentions it cannot
take into account
everything that it ought to
as it acts so in acting it screws up no
matter what no matter who it trusts and
going back to the reference to hamlet
earlier on a few paragraphs back when
hegel was saying well you know this is a
more sophisticated attitude that doesn't
work either because not acting until you
get more information that is also
a way of acting and so you're going to
find yourself
drawing willy-nilly into one side or the
other so the you know the grand total of
this is you can't act in any way
that is not going to bring about some
sort of
opposition and catastrophe
so it violates the other gives it the
right to itself so coming back to this
side in following the god it knows it
got a hold of what was not revealed and
pays the penalty
of trusting a knowledge
whose ambiguity we're going to come back
to that for such as its nature also
becomes explicit for consciousness and a
warning to it
so ambiguity now this becomes
apparent to consciousness but all too
late
the oracle said this and then you act
and then you're like oh crap it actually
meant this instead right now this is not
a a tragic example this is actually from
history but think about the story of
crisis who is the king of lydia a very
powerful kingdom in what is nowadays
turkey and the persians are rising as a
power and he's thinking maybe i should
crush them so he sends to the greek
oracle and he says should i fight the
persians and uh
the oracle says if you do a great
kingdom will be destroyed now he thinks
well that must be the the persians
because i'm going to destroy them and as
it turns out nope that's his own kingdom
that's going to be destroyed and so this
is a prime example of finding out this
ambiguity only too late we also have a
similar ambiguity
in the oracle that is given to oedipus
that then he acts upon
fleeing his adoptive father and mother
he winds up killing his birth father and
marrying his birth mother
trying to not bring about the oracle uh
he actually brings it about we might
also think now hegel's not talking about
this but it's kind of on my mind
about the famous oracle
that socrates himself did not consult
but his friend kind of a smart ass uh at
delphi says is you know
is socrates the wisest man and the
oracle says there's nobody wiser than
socrates and then socrates is like
what the hell could that mean let me go
and and prove by disproving these are
modes of handle action the oracle i'm
going to go and find somebody who's
really smart and then i'll i'll
certainly see that i'm not as wise as
they are it turns out that nobody's
actually wise and socrates comes to the
conclusion i'm wise and that i know the
limits of my own knowledge and wisdom
and these other schmucks don't right
there's an ambiguity there as maybe
actually not just a single ambiguity but
nested ambiguities and we should talk
about this term
zvay deutsche kait right
two possible meanings in the same thing
or maybe multiple meanings we use other
words besides ambiguous like polysemis
you know sort of a related idea means
different things signifies
different things and that's what's
happening here there's a signification
that's taking place
what are the examples that he gives the
ravings of the priestess okay that's the
oracle right
the inhuman shape of the witches the
voices of trees and birds dreams and so
forth
are not the ways in which truth
manifests itself
they are taken
as ways in which truth manifests itself
that's why people consult them right and
if you think about the many different
ways in which divination
or consulting the spiritual powers can
take place ranging from examining the
guts of of animals to looking at the
flights of birds to casting euro straws
or flipping coins or you know rolling
dice or any of these sorts of things
they are marked by a
very strong ambiguity and there's a
disconnect with
truth instead he says
they are warning signs
of deception of an absence of
self-possession
of the singularity and contingency
of the knowing
isn't this interesting the knowing
itself is not a reliable knowledge of
truth instead it's deception
it's singular and contingent and he says
or
here we move to the next part in other
words the opposite power
which is violated by consciousness is
present as expressed law and valid right
so
it's kind of is that a plan as i'm there
is he saying the same thing twice
express law
and valid right gulty geract
or are these two
aspects of the same thing well he's
going to talk about two laws right the
law of the state and the law of the
family that we've encountered from the
you know beginning of the spirit section
in which the the discussion was the
conflict between the law of the state
something that was in fact
uh you know open
public and then the law of the family
which is also the law of the gods and we
saw this clash in the tragedy antigone
but we can see this in others
as well and the acting consciousness is
getting itself in trouble
with
both of these now
now the acting consciousness is not
taking the side of the law of the state
as for example creon right or the law of
the family as for example antigone right
or uh something else as a matter of fact
who would be a prime example of this
hymen
uh the son of crayon who is an acting
consciousness who acts who tries to
remonstrate with his father and argue
him into not taking this stand against
antigone who he's engaged to and then
goes and and attacks his father and also
uh kills himself right violating both of
these laws leaving creon
in ruin
well
i mean that's that's one example among
many that we might be able to bring up
the other what's lacking there of course
is the consultation of the gods in that
case but he says um
uh the opposite power is
present as whether law of the family or
of the state
consciousness
on the other hand
followed its own way of knowing and
concealed from itself
what was openly revealed now that's
that's an interesting thing to say
because what that implies is that in
these tragedies
if the character was looking closely
enough if they proceeded in a more
cautious manner
maybe they could have seen what was not
being
made explicit what was not revealed
before it came to bite them
and then maybe they wouldn't be in
conflict with these things but that's
not how action really works in drama
frankly in a lot of history either it's
pretty rare that people are
wise and cautious right
so he goes on and he says
the truth of the opposing powers of the
content of the knowledge
and of consciousness is the result this
is very important both are equally right
everybody's got some
rightness on their side
nobody's completely right
so it's impossible
and this really is the tragic situation
it's impossible to do
justice to
to reconcile the truth of all of these
voices all of these
these legitimate um ethical
powers or forces
or living norms and so he says
therefore in their antithesis in the
gegenzadz between them the opposition
between them
both are equally
wrong
now
who's actually going to have to pay for
being wrong the laws don't pay anything
right the laws are what they are
and that's because unless they are
embodied in a consciousness
embodied in somebody who acts on behalf
of them they they can't pay any penalty
crayon in being the law of the state in
the antigone he can pay a penalty his
family is ruined right he's lost
everything and he didn't solve the
messed up situation that his
brother-in-law slash nephew odyssey or
oedipus uh left behind right
um we could say similar things about
other tragedies as well when somebody
does embody the law of the family as
antigone did or the law of the state
then the law can actually
pay for being wrong so like it says the
action in being carried out demonstrates
their unity
in the natural downfall of both powers
and both
self-conscious characters and here's
where we're getting ready to move
beyond tragedy
hegel
doesn't want to just say well you know
in the ancient world we had you know
the religion of art and when we get to
the point of language we have three main
kinds of language epic that's cool
tragedy that's cooler yet comedy well
that's coolest but also kind of a
you know end of all of this
no he has to show some intrinsic
connection
between these at least conceptual
connections if not historical
connections and that is part of what
he's doing by talking about the downfall
here of both powers
then he talks about reconciliation the
reconciliation of the opposition
with itself and here he uses this term
lethal
lathe is a legendary
river but it's also a concept
forgetfulness
it comes from the word
lanthane to conceal right
and
heidegger is going to make a lot out of
out of this right truth is alethea you
know unforgetting unconcealing hegel's
not yet working with this he's thinking
about this in terms of actual
forgetting or
wiping away or dealing with things in
such a way that there's no longer a
crisis
going on between them so there's two
different possibilities here we have a
lower possibility and we have a higher
possibility
um
he says the the lathe a
of the underworld
uh the reconciliation takes place in
death
and and we do have characters die and
they go to the underworld and that's
that and in the underworld what what
sort of uh existence do they have um now
this is actually coming uh i'm gonna
take something here that's a really
interesting suggestion from a fantasy
series ursula k le guin where she has
the dry land and she says that the
people who continue on there as shades
exist only as names and shadows
isn't that a brilliant way of talking
about the greek underworld
they exist as names and as shadows as an
identity that is not the totality of who
they were
and as shadows not living people
okay so that's one side and hegel is
going to leave that behind at this point
because that's not where the attention
really is going to focus
he says or the lathe a of the
upper world
as
absolution
absolution
now notice what he says here not from
guilt
for consciousness cannot deny its guilt
because it committed the act
but
from the crime and so there's a split
here right
the crime the sin the hamartia
in greek the the evil deed the wrong
deed the thing that turned out to be not
good but bad
you can be absolved from that
you can't be absolved entirely from the
guilt which you carry around yourself
you are the one who accuses yourself
and there is this possibility of
absolution
but not only absolution he says
also the peace of mind following
now here's a second
a second thing
atonement for the crime so it's not just
you know somebody
maybe a god pronounces oh you're
absolved you know everything's cool
there's also atonement involved and
atonement itself is a further kind of
handle right action anybody can be
contrite doing something after you've
screwed things up
that's a whole different matter isn't it
atoning is something where you have to
commit yourself
and he goes on and he says
both are oblivion
the vanishness of the reality and the
action of the powers or substance of
their individualities
and of the powers of the abstract
thought
of good and evil
why
none of them by itself is the essence
none of them is the these and the
essence that we've been looking for
which rather is the repose of the whole
within itself this reconciliation allows
the jarring contradictory
hole to actually form something like a
system
that makes sense
what how does he describe this the
unmoved unity of fate
the peaceful existence and consequent
inactivity and lack of vitality
of family and government the two laws
right
or the things representing the two laws
rather
and the equal honor and consequent
indifferent unreality of apollo
and the furies the god who knows
and what was not revealed
all of this
becomes kind of flattened out
no longer
as effective and he says
the return of their spiritual life and
activity now we come back to this into
the unitary being of zeus and and
actually miller's translation just says
einfach and zeus you know uh the simple
the one fold zeus that is
encompassing all of this zeus is not a
character
in this as he is in some things like
prometheus you know bound or you know
things like that in this case
a stand-in for fate for the totality
of the system and we arrive at a point
where we can have a sort of quiescence
and an acquiescence in
what has taken place
and
we're beyond in a certain respect
abstract good and evil i know that
sounds a little niche and beyond good
and evil we are beyond an abstract way
of understanding it because they're made
sense of within the entire
totality
so we've really come a long ways with
what happens in
a tragedy according to hegel and this is
priming us for being able to say
maybe tragedy wasn't exactly what we
thought it was it does also help to
explain one thing that hegel doesn't
talk about here but referenced earlier
that old idea of tragedy that aristotle
may have originated he's certainly one
of the first people to talk about it
saying that tragedy produces a catharsis
a cleansing a purification of the
spectator
of what their feelings their emotions
their path a
of fear and pity
there's nothing left to fear
in this vast tableau of interconnected
systems or one system
and
is there any pity left to feel as well
perhaps not so
that is another function of what is
going on here
and so you know a lot happening this is
a quite important transition
paragraph